former Trump campaign advisor George
papadopolis reported to jail today he's
serving a 14-day sentence supposedly
that sentence is necessary so that
robert muller can protect the rest of us
an American democracy itself from the
mortal threat of Russian operatives
hiding in the bushes is there a single
person in the United States of America
who believes that and if they don't
believe that if they know it's alive
because obviously it is what is the
point of putting George papadopolis
behind bars or any of these people many
are being financially ruined their lives
destroyed by the Muller investigation is
achieving anything is it part of a
partisan Vendetta what is the point
Simona Papadopoulos is George
papadopolis his wife she's been a
tireless advocate in his behalf she
joins us tonight
first of course our sympathies to you
that your husband is now behind bars I
just want to make sure absolutely clear
on this is there evidence that he worked
for the Russian government to subvert
our democracy high tariffs thanks for
inviting me
home tonight I feel a lot of emotions
most mostly I feel defeated and scared
scared not only for the 14 days of jail
time but mostly because something alike
as it's completely groundless and based
on inexistent contacts with Russian
officials I always stressed and I've
been very vocal about to the possibility
for Georgia to draw his plea agreement
it worked
today and to the jail with a lot of
courage and resilience but at the same
time I feel this decision very unfair
I'm not talking about the decision of
the judge but all the incriminating
process fabricated by Muller this is
clearly fabrication we know today many
heavy dances came out recently about is
a zero level of involvement in the
Russia collusion scheme so I don't
understand honestly how miss remember
the date of the meeting with the multis
professor and not as some channel said
his Russian contacts could lead today to
the this jailing was
in where where I walked them in a very
stressful way I feel honestly defeated
this is a and this is the democracy as a
whole was undermined I think this should
never happen to any citizen and an
American honey human being involved and
destroyed in assassinated in this way
because today there is the stigma on the
gorge reputation as for being a traitor
he never betrayed anyone
he simply didn't deliver the information
that the Mueller was probably trying to
extort from him I'm sorry if I'm very
straight talking about this point but it
is my strong belief it looks to me an
awkward situation that created that put
it on all the is life and also my life I
married Josh during this you know and i
profoundly believe the name and I am a
personal witness of the case I know
Joseph NIF so there's no Russian agent I
know this man since five years and I
can't understand how the meeting with
this Muftis professor could lead to the
crossfire hurricane first and that to
George in Qatar incarceration today he
volunteered to help the Trump campaign
that may have been his real crime we
shouldn't care if an innocent man goes
to jail even for two weeks and nobody
cares and we should care exactly
Simona thank you very much I know that
you care of course it's your husband
thanks for joining us thank you so much